WHICH IS PART OF THE OFFICE OF
MANAGEMENT AND BUDGET.
CNN IS SUING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OVER THE
WHITE HOUSE CREDENTIALED
SUSPENSION OF THE GENERAL CHIEF
WHITE HOUSE REPORTER.
FOX NEWS MEDIA ANALYST AND HOST
OF FOX NEWS MEDIA BUZZ HOWARD
HOWARD KURTZ WHAT'S AT STAKE FOR
CNN AND THE PRESIDENT.
>> WE ARE TAKING ACTION AFTER
THE WHITE HOUSE
>> IT'S A LAWSUIT CAME AFTER THE
WHITE HOUSE YANKED THE
CREDENTIALS OF ACOSTA WHO HAS A
HISTORY OF LECTURING AND
CONFRONTING THE PRESIDENT
FOLLOWING THIS CLASH.
>> THAT'S ENOUGH.
>> PARDON ME, MA'AM --
>> I TELL YOU WHAT, CNN SHOULD
BE ASHAMED OF ITSELF HAVING YOU
WORK FOR THEM.
YOU ARE A RUDE, TERRIBLE PERSON.
>> SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS CALLED
THE SUIT MORE GRANDSTANDING FROM
CNN WHO HAS NEARLY OTHER THAN 50
CREDENTIALED --DASH REFUSED TO
SURRENDER THE MICROPHONE TO AN
INTERN SO THAT OTHER REPORTERS
MIGHT ASK THEIR QUESTIONS AND
THIS WAS NOT THE FIRST TIME HE
ACTED INAPPROPRIATELY.
SANDERS DIDN'T REPEAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S HIGHEST
CONTENTION, THAT ACOSTA LANDED
HANDS ON THE INTERN.
HE SAYS, THE FIRST AMENDMENT
GIVES JOURNALISTS THE RIGHT    R
GIVES JOURNALISTS THE RIGHT    G
GIVES JOURNALISTS THE RIGHT    T
GIVES JOURNALISTS THE RIGHT    O
HOLD OFFICIALS ACCOUNTABLE'S AND
ASK TOUGH QUESTIONS.
>> WE ARE ASKING FOR EMERGENCY
RELIEF BECAUSE EVERY DAY THIS
PASS IS REVOKED AS A
FIRST AMENDMENT VIOLATION AND
IRREPARABLE HARM UNDER THE LAW.
>> THE PRESIDENT CONSTANTLY
CRITICIZES THE NETWORK.
>> I DON'T TAKE FAKE NEWS.
>> ONCE WE DID THIS WRESTLING
VIDEO AIMED AT CNN.
THE CORRESPONDENCE WHITE HOUSE
ASSOCIATION IS BACKING CNN, BUT